hello six o'clock I've met karishi this
is the early rundown making news today
as the winter crisis grips the NHS Sky
News takes to the road to see the
pressures faced by healthcare workers
first hand
German media reports the Berlin will
send leopard tanks to Kiev and allow
partner countries to do the same
Sky News hears the U.S will follow suit
with its own Abrams tanks with a deal
from both countries expected as soon as
today
also a report lays bare the severe
economic disparity between the North and
South as political leaders gather in
Manchester to discuss the leveling up
agenda
the boss of Royal Mail faces another
round of questioning by MPS after
hundreds of complaints about evidence he
gave last week
and we'll have a full run through of
this morning's front and back pages
[Music]
hi money good to see you on the early
rundown so leading the news this
Wednesday with the NHS facing crisis Sky
News has seen firsthand the reality of
working on the front line of Emergency
Care Ambulance response times are
currently the worst on record and the
NHS is struggling to cope with a surge
in demand this winter we heard about the
daily pressures for patients and
paramedics who often face cues outside a
d of up to 15 ambulances our Midlands
correspondents Becky Johnson joined a
crew for their 12-hour shift and here's
her report
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the first call of the day for
ambulance technician Dan and paramedic
Danny
so on the way to an hourly man at the
minute who's got swelling and pain to
one of his arms following some Falls
morning
some injury looks serious you've done a
number on that thing yeah he's got one
Advanced Parkinson's bless him he fell
two days ago but his wife delayed
calling an ambulance
[Music]
the intense pressure on the NHS and
advice on recent strike days put her off
don't say on the television
only call if there's some matter of life
and death no don't worry if you fall if
someone Falls over give us a call
however full the hospitals are patients
like Edward need to be seen
they persuade him to go to a e people
are a bit scared like to call ambulances
because they think they're going to be
stuck in the corridor for a long time or
in the back of the ambulance straight
into that
very unusual
it's often a very different story this
winter there's some days where we sat
outside and maybe 10 15 ambulances sat
outside Hospital we've all got patients
on the back
and the next call a category one a
reminder of the need for ambulances to
be able to respond immediately yeah so
we've got an elderly lady
through that she's
had seizure of some description they
quickly established there's a problem
with the patient's heart ECGs are all
over the place to be honest with you I
couldn't use some kind of facing her
heart rate is so low there's a danger it
could stop heart rate at the minute is
2929 symptomatic they start treatment
and are calling ahead to the hospital in
Coventry
ETA five minutes to you mate you're
definitely want to release us
she goes straight in for emergency
surgery to fit a pacemaker when you see
how quickly they have to move on a
serious call like that you can
understand the frustration and concern
on the days when they can't get to those
category one calls because they're
queuing outside hospitals this time they
were able to save the patient but at the
moment there are no guarantees can
things go on as they have been for the
last few weeks no things can't go on it
as they are really
nearly the cardiac lady on a normal kind
of busy day we would normally see that
would be a massive delay
um and potentially resulted in
somebody's life
have you ever known it to be
like no never never something has got to
give the question is what with long
delays strikes and thousands of excess
deaths the pressure on the NHS is
unprecedented and the route to recovery
far from Clear Becky Johnston's Sky News
Coventry
now let me just tell you that at two
o'clock tomorrow afternoon Sky News will
be hosting a live phone in show called
NHS your say we want to hear your
experiences of course good or bad call
on
0208167 double two double zero leave us
a message for your chance to speak on
the program
later on Thursday tomorrow we'll be
hosting a special debate on the issues
facing the NHS simply scan this QR code
that will bring up an email form for you
to apply to be part of the audience at
University Hospital Coventry We'll be
asking simply can the NHS survive you
can also apply in fact by mailing NHS
crisis emailing NHS crisis at sky.uk the
debate broadcast at seven o'clock here
on Sky News tomorrow evening
there are multiple reports in German
media that Berlin has decided it will
send tanks to Ukraine it's understood
Chancellor Schultz will allow other
nations operating the german-made
leopard tank to send their own
Consignments of the vehicle it faced
weeks of pressure to allow shipment to
the tanks seen as crucial to Ukraine's
defense against the Russian invasion but
was likely waiting on the U.S to send
its own Abrams Tanks which now also look
imminent we'll have more of that in a
moment first though Siobhan Robbins on
the anticipated announcements from
Germany
it's a question which has been dividing
allies for weeks will Germany release
the leopard two battle tanks to fight in
Ukraine now finally an answer seems
imminent a diplomatic source told me
German approval for Poland to send its
leopard two tanks as expected this week
with German media reporting the
chancellor is also likely to send some
of their own stock nothing is official
until Olaf Schultz makes an announcement
and one of the questions which has been
delaying this decision is whether by
sending battle tanks they could escalate
the war in Ukraine by acting alone
billing could be a Target so I'm told
that Germany has been looking for a
similar commitment from allies
particularly the U.S
this is what America has on the table
it's much prized Abrams a speculation
swirled it was poised to send them as
part of a joint package of heavy weapons
the Pentagon refused to be drawn I have
no announcements to make at this time
and when and if we do we'll be sure to
let you know Britain has already
confirmed its sending 14 Challenger twos
vital weapons in a conflict President
Putin is showing no desire to end soon
the only way to last in peace is to make
it clear to Putin that he will not win
on the battlefield
therefore we must provide heavier and
more advanced systems on the
battlefields of Ukraine troops in Soviet
era equipment are desperate for modern
machines experts say a delivery of
Battle Tanks could be crucial it does
give them a punch it certainly evens out
the odds on the battlefield and it gives
Ukraine the option of an attack that at
the moment is a little bit less likely
for them to be able to do and succeed
the German government says a decision
will come soon but refuse to comment
further
while the weight continues in Ukraine
there are fresh hopes that the tanks
they've been pleading for could soon be
on their way Siobhan Robbins Sky News
Berlin
so any announcement from Germany will
likely coincide with one out of the U.S
then Sky News understands that could
come as soon as today Russia has
responded to that news saying that any
tanks sent by the United States would be
destroyed Mark Stone has more now from
Washington
well it was only a few days ago that the
Americans were giving a firm no to
Ukrainian requests for their battle tank
to be deployed to the front line in
Ukraine but at the same time almost in
the same breath the Americans were
saying stay tuned and I think there has
certainly you could generously call it
an evolution of thought that has taken
place by the Americans and by the the
rest of the western allies
um ungenerously I think you could call
it a bit of a debacle certainly it is
presented a split in opinion by Western
allies who have tried as much as they
can to be United over the war in Ukraine
and how to counter the Russian offensive
it is clear though that over the course
of the past few days something's changed
and we can now expect an announcement
from the White House to come at any time
now today is very very likely I think an
announcement that we'll see uh in one
form or another American battle tanks
pre being prepared to be sent to Ukraine
the details though well we will await
those I think what this will do is is
um unlock the German reluctance remember
the Germans had always said they didn't
want to send their own battle tanks to
Ukraine unless the Americans and others
did the same the Americans have got
existing concerns over the supply chain
their M1 Abrams is a very complex bit of
equipment they were worried that the the
jet fuel for example that it needs to to
get it moving is not readily uh
available on the front lines in eastern
Ukraine there are supply issues there
are maintenance issues and so over time
I think they will work out how they can
resolve these so that they can get their
own tank to the front line but yes um
this opens up what was a difficult
moment for the alliances they tried to
find some Unity over this issue with
battle tanks that the ukrainians say
they need but um the Americans say said
stay tuned I think all eyes on the White
House today
meanwhile the families of two British
men killed in Ukraine say they
sacrificed their lives trying to help
others 28 year old Chris parry and 48
year old Andrew Bagshaw were
volunteering in eastern Ukraine they
were evacuating civilians from the town
of solidar when it came under attack
from Russian forces the family of Mr
Bagshaw spoke earlier from their home in
New Zealand
it has been confirmed that our son Dr
Andrew Bagshaw has died
he and the colleague Chris Parry were
attempting to rescue an elderly woman
from solidar he took many personal risks
and saved many lives
we loved him we are very proud of
everything that he did there
in a statement Chris parry's family said
his selfless determination in helping
the old young and disadvantaged there
has made us and his larger family
extremely proud we never imagined we
would be saying goodbye to Chris when he
had such a full life ahead of him he was
a caring son fantastic brother and best
friend to so many and a loving partner
to Olga
I'm going to bring you some breaking
news on Sky news this morning a
metropolitan police officer has pleaded
guilty to several counts of child sexual
offenses yesterday PC Hussein shahab
pleaded guilty to four counts of sexual
activity with a girl aged 13 to 15
between March and September 2019 that
was before his service in the met also
three counts of making indecent
photographs of a child and one count of
engaging in sexual communication with a
child no verdict was recorded in a
further four counts and in fact we're
told by the Mets the 22 year old will
now face an accelerated misconduct
process
now it's one of the government's
Landmark programs leveling up a
commitment to spread opportunity and
investment more equally across the
United Kingdom new figures today though
awesome rather cold water on that idea
the ippr state of the north report
highlights a severe Regional disparity
between the North and South it also
points out that Nationwide the UK
receives one of the lowest levels of
Investments of any Rich Nation elevari
Aurora is with us now talking about
pouring cold water that's very good
isn't that kind of a little scent tell
us about this report perhaps not
surprising that this organization based
in the north said they're hard done by
but some of the figures are quite
staggering here they really are and I
think you're right I think a lot of
people in the north will not be shocked
or surprised at all by these findings I
think it's a reality that they're living
every day and therefore this is really
just confirmation of their lived
experience so this ippr report there are
left at leaning Think Tank and
essentially they're looking into the
lack of investment in the north and
their findings suggest that there's vast
inequalities and systematic
underinvestment when it comes to
research and development when it comes
to social infrastructure and transport
and they're basically trying to say that
productivity and hourly pay those are
the kind of two major things that are
massively lower in the north than they
are in the South and therefore that's
underpinning some of those Regional
inequalities now this is coming all at
the same time where we've got that
Convention of the north happening today
it's going to be attended by you know
big kind of political heavyweights like
Michael Gove his shadow Lisa and Andy
and also Andy Burnham the greater
Manchester mayor they're going to be
speaking at that event and and the
convention is essentially a kind of
annual event for businesses and
political Civic leaders to kind of get
together and essentially try and find
ways and discuss ways of improving the
kind of financial Outlook of the north
now the issue here is we had the
leveling up fund last week that was
announced quite heavily criticized I
think a lot of people that it was not
necessarily evenly distributed between
the South and the north but also we had
Andy Street the greater the West
Midlands sorry uh Metro mayor basically
kind of criticizing the government for a
begging Bowl culture when it comes to
devolved Powers Regional devolved Powers
so now we have a situation where
essentially will especially Northern
voters perhaps voters in general get
quite skeptical about promises around
leveling up and you know just you know
getting rid of regional disparities when
so far it doesn't necessarily look
especially if you look at this report
like the government has really made good
on some of those leveling up promises
and could that potentially down the line
before the next election lead to the
collapse of the red wall big big
questions we wish you've seen that yeah
Forefront to their agenda has been for
for a long time hasn't it well that's a
big meeting today in Manchester uh while
that happens it's Wednesday it's going
to be a big meeting in the House of
Commons the weekly prime minister's
questions I'm sure it's going to get a
rough ride isn't he he definitely is I
think it's a very very tricky day for
him on so many different levels I think
at the moment the opposition have so
much ammunition they have the you know
Nadeem zahari ongoing controversy we
have the BBC chairman Boris Johnson 800
000 pound loan controversy and then we
also have this new report about uh the
lack of investment in the north so take
your pick in terms of you know Choose
Your Weapon as it were I think at the
moment we have Nadim zahari still in
post despite the fact that MPS like
Caroline noakes uh have essentially said
he should step aside until the
investigation is over just to kind of
clear the air and create a real kind of
a sense of transparency and honesty
which is obviously supposedly which is
your next priority and I've been
speaking to a former minister to try and
gauge the kind of temperature in the
Tory party and this Minister was a
former Minister was telling me they
think that Richardson actually sacked
Nadim zahari long ago they're shocked
that he hasn't sacked him and actually
they want him to be sacked before prime
minister's questions to almost pull the
rug from underneath kirst Armor's feet
and essentially kind of nullify some of
his political attacks never mind
obviously the Boris Johnson controversy
going on so key date for The Diary is
the 7th of September sorry 7th of
February which is the date for the party
gate evidence but also when Richard
shark will be speaking to the dcms
committee and of course before that key
date today at 12 o'clock few hours ago
we will see if there's any Movement
zahar we went with before that thank you
Murray and uh don't forget of course you
can watch prime minister's questions
live in its entirety here on Sky News it
all starts at midday
right it's Wednesday morning here are
top stories on the early rundown with
ambulance response times currently the
worst on record Sky News has seen
firsthand the reality of working on the
front line of Emergency Care there are
multiple reports in German media that
Berlin has decided it will send tanks to
Ukraine to boost its Firepower in the
war against Russia and reporters we've
been talking about has found a severe
disparity between the North and South as
political leaders prepare to gather in
Manchester today to discuss the leveling
aperture
[Music]
and plenty of those stories make today's
front pages let's look at the Ft
reporting on Germany's anticipated
announcement that it will send tanks to
Ukraine
the guardian leads without story calling
it a historic move
the telegraph says it's a hammer blow
for Russia
the Metro focuses on that ippr report
with the headline it's Grim up north
the times looks at a warning that the
UK's economic prospects have declined
leaving a multi-billion pound hole ahead
of the spring budget in March
the eye says the treasury is ruling out
any tax cuts after being surprised by a
recent government borrowing levels and
the mail points to those borrowing
figures saying it shows the need for
growth
the express meanwhile warns the
chancellor against any move to increase
the pension age
the mirror leads with mistakes made by
the probation service after a review
Into the murder of Zara Alina calling
them deadly failings
uh today's star reports honored alerts
about Chinese spies supposedly using
everyday gadgets against us
and the sun says a UK filmed game show
based on the Netflix hit squid game
turned to some real life horror for
contestants
now if you want to see any of those
front pages again or indeed read the
stories then do scan the QR code on your
screen that will take you to the press
review on the Sky News website
let's have a look at some other stories
this Wednesday and Mike Pence has become
the latest high profile us political
figure to have classified documents
found in his private home the former
vice president's lawyer says the
materials have been handed over to the
FBI the discovery puts him in the
company of his old boss Donald Trump and
President Joe Biden
Chris Hipkins has been sworn in as New
Zealand's prime minister replacing who
resigned unexpectedly last week with his
labor party trailing their conservative
Rivals Mr Hipkins may be in for a tough
general election later this year
this is the biggest privilege and
responsibility of my life I'm energized
and excited by the challenges that liar
hit
the Deputy Prime Minister and I both
take today's appointments very seriously
as prime minister I acknowledge the
important nature of my role in advising
The Sovereign and the governor general
meanwhile there were emotional scenes as
Jacinda ardern left Parliament joined by
dozens of her former staff members and
admirers the former prime minister will
stay on as a backbencher until April
also tell you about more Street battles
between protesters and police in Peru's
Capital Lima violence there has killed
more than 50 people since last month
when Pedro Castillo was ousted as
president and detained after trying to
dissolve Congress his support is
demanding he be freed and returned to
office
okay let's see what's coming up a little
later today shall we just after eight
this morning Cavalli will be speaking to
the shadow leveling up secretary Lisa
nandy about the state of the north
report at 8 20 we'll hear from Ukraine's
former deputy Minister of Defense Elena
frolova and discuss the prospect of
Tanks being sent to Ukraine then at 9 30
the filmmaker and activist Richard
Curtis will talk about as star-studded
campaign against Banks financing fossil
fuel expansion
now don't go away the business news is
next including why the boss of Royal
Mail will once again face questions by
MPS plus the defense companies seeing a
boost in value
[Music]
hello welcome back let's have a look at
the business news now and the boss of
Royal Mail is facing another round of
questioning by MPS the business selects
committee says it received hundreds of
complaints about Simon Thompson's
evidence last week including his denials
that the company tracks employees
productivity through their handheld
computers
the customer
the Aerospace and defense company
Raytheon has reported strong fourth
quarter profits beating analysts
estimates increased travel demand
boosted the need for its jet engines
parts and services defense contractor
Lockheed Martin also be Wall Street
expectations with increased sales of a
range of products including of weapons
being sent to help Ukraine
Robert Murdoch has scrapped his proposal
to merge a News Corp and fox a decade
after splitting them up the billionaire
media Mogul sent a letter to both media
companies indicating that he and his son
fox chief executive Lachlan Murdoch had
determined that it wouldn't be optimal
for shareholders
Amazon's UK operations are being hit by
a strike action for the first time today
after workers at a warehouse in Coventry
walked out at midnight the GMB union
says it expects around 300 Amazon
employees to take part they've been in a
months-long negotiation over pay marred
by Amazon increasing starting wages by
50 pence an hour last year Amazon
insists its pay is competitive but
workers on strike say it's far from
enough to live on
you know it's not an easy decision
because we're losing money from here as
well yeah as we walked out we're not
going to get paid we are going to get
paid something but it's compared to what
we're gonna obviously it's nothing but
uh you know for the future obviously uh
we need it as everything has gone up
everything has doubled up Fuel Gas
Electric Grocery and what payrolls have
you got unfortunately it's not enough
okay we could have a look at the markets
what's happening in Asia huge gain right
now on the Hang Seng in Hong Kong the
Nikkei still up dropped a bit since uh
last hour but there you go
as for the currency markets the pound
let's have a look trading against the
dollar what is it 123 up very marginally
there against the Euro it is 113 and uh
Brent crude pretty flat at the moment 86
US dollars per barrel
let's take a check on the business Pages
the Ft reports that activist fund
Elliott management has become one of the
largest shareholders in Japanese
conglomerates diet Nippon printing
building a 300 million dollar stake
the guardian crunches the numbers of the
UK's record borrowing last month that
came out yesterday reporting that it was
pushed up by Energy bill support
and the eye says there's a jump in firms
facing critical financial distress and
the UK it may have a wave of companies
and businesses going bust this year
now Ian King will be here at 10 o'clock
this morning rounding up all the city
news and plenty of interviews much more
join Ian King live on Sky News 10
o'clock this morning
right now though weather time
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
this week looks mainly dry and Mild but
the southeast will take time to warm up
it will be mostly mild but fairly cloudy
through the rush hour with Hill fog and
outbreaks of rain in the north but
Southern Britain will be cold there'll
be a patchy Frost there and dense fog in
places
hello welcome back this is the early
rundown these are our top stories this
Wednesday as the winter crisis grips the
NHS Sky News has taken to the roads to
see the pressures faced by healthcare
workers
German media is reporting that Berlin
will send leopard tanks to Kiev and will
be joined by the US which will send its
own Abrams tanks
the report has laid bare the severe
economic disparity between the North and
South as political leaders gather in
Manchester to discuss the leveling up
agenda
[Music]
thank you
now nearly two years after They seized
power in a military coup myanmar's
ruling Junta is promising free and fair
elections but with Civil War continuing
the military is accused of a violent
Crackdown to crush dissent in the face
of a growing armed resistance the
country has been largely cut off to
Western journalists since the coup but
our Asia correspondent Cordelia Lynch
has gained rare access
since the coup more than 2700
pro-democracy activists and other
civilians have been killed and more than
13 600 detained the UN has accused the
regime of a flagrant disregard for human
life bombarding areas with airstrikes in
what could amount to war crimes the
country's ousted leader aung sang tsuchi
is serving a 33-year prison sentence a
Cordelia visited Napier door Bagan and
Yangon all in Junta controlled Myanmar
and this is her special report
really don't
driving through the darkness in Myanmar
we're on a packed bus in a place some
call The Land of Shadows
as our Convoy comes to a stop the
glimpse of the theatrics to come
oh yeah
[Music]
they've been preparing for this moment
for weeks performance shipped in to show
their loyalty all for a parade
celebrating British rule 75
years ago
a chance to try and prove to the world
and its own people it's thriving
[Music]
foreign
seized power in a coup nearly two years
later the tanks are rolling back in
perhaps an obvious bookend for the city
of napador a military Utopia built on
hubris
very little has been seen of Life inside
Myanmar since the coup Western
journalists rarely given any absence but
this is a moment the military want to
share and perhaps feels strong
for it's been accused of torture and
mass killings condemned by the UN and
sanctioned not that money looks like any
issue here
the military overthrew a democratically
elected government
slide victory was electoral fraud
taking over the Junta has locked up and
killed opponents
[Music]
man at the hell senior General minang
line the situation he says is now under
control and he's promising the people a
vote
is
foreign
[Music]
but this is a piece of performance art
from the cradle of the coup
outside this theater there is real and
intense fighting
peace currently as elusive as democracy
foreign
we wait six days to get clearance to
leave the capital this is a country well
known for jailing journalists it is
largely because of Brave local ones and
those willing to risk it all to film
that we've heard anything about life
here beyond the junta's claims
well after lengthy discussions with the
military government we've been given
permission to film elsewhere in Myanmar
it is a chance to see and hear from
people beyond the seat of power
we're on our way to began a tourist
destination they presumably hoped would
showcase how secure and stable the
country is
the mass protests are long gone now Mass
surveillance is the talking point
[Music]
it's Majestic here
but within minutes we see a hint of the
conflict Beyond
soldiers carrying supplies crossing the
famous erawadi river where Rebellion
still rages an area we were told not to
go to
locals tell us it's nothing new to these
Waters
and some are deeply anxious
we've decided to protect the identities
of everyone we've spoken to those who do
talk risk being detained and
interrogated
one there is intense fighting over there
to cross the river do you feel unsafe
yes we don't have any safety we could
die at any moment
how close are we to some of the fighting
it's not that far it's about three miles
away from here
will burn down the whole village the man
shouts that's allegedly the voice of a
soldier about 20 miles away
the military is accused of torching
communities
[Music]
targeting civilians in airstrikes
and labeling opponents as terrorists
the tap midor is facing a growing armed
resistance from the people's Defense
Force and ethnic armed groups
the currents of a civil war shifting
and the military doesn't control vast
swathes of the country
over there is the pukoku bridge and it
leads to the Magway region and we know
that fighting is taking place there but
we can't cross because we've been told
by the government we're not allowed to
and there are checkpoints on either side
you don't feel far from the trouble here
though and local people have told us
they can hear the clashes across the
river
foreign
however you frame the balance of power
the economy is fragile here
many desperately waiting for the arrival
of more tourists
my life has got Wars since the coup I
almost lost my job my savings are gone
we all depend on the visitors for our
livelihoods what has life been like
since the coup I hear the sound of
fighting from the other side of the
river at night do you think there can be
free and fair elections here I don't
think so
they are using their weapons and their
power to threaten the people
I don't agree with them
most soaking up this sacred Sunset are
Burmese
it may be safe inside the city but with
conflict around the country Outsiders
wanting a pilgrimage to these pagodas
they need to take a leap of faith
we're on our way to Yangon when we
suddenly get a call from the military
spokesperson
he's been hard to reach and has done
very few International interviews the
military is accused of burning villages
running indiscriminate airstrikes
torture mass killings
do you have any intention of ending the
bloodshed
the machine
uh foreign
but the UN says the regime has
deliberately targeted civilians and
committed war crimes
around the mistrouded lakes of Yangon
life looks normal
but when you look back
to where those birds fly
you see where thousands once marched
a revolution has fallen silent
many protesters fled many are in prison
the days of anti-coo tattoos are all but
erased
why do you think people wanted those
tattoos everybody was hyped up
that's why they did it
and at the time it was like they were
showing their strength what about now do
you think people would feel comfortable
having those tattoos
no when people travel overseas or
domestically they were inspected those
who travel regularly had to cover them
with additional ink
some people choose
not to travel at all
does it feel like the military is
watching everyone they spread the
information around and remind others
that if they do the same they will be in
the same trouble as a result people are
terrified
there's a pervasive sense of fear
the feeling that your every move is
being watched that can be a potent
propaganda tool
the stakes too high to share your
frustration
what does life feel like in Myanmar
right now we live in fear and insecurity
it is impossible to protest because
young peoples are being control and
arrested that's why the youth are going
toward the arm resistance
do you feel like the Junta the security
forces are monitoring people in the
resistance simply monitor what young
people also doing online the internet is
how they control the youth
you can force a city to play ball
publicly
but you can't crush the sentiment
this is a fractured country and in
places now very violent with that
Jeopardy it's very hard to see the
military rushing to let go
Cordelia Lynch with that special report
you're watching the early run down here
our top stories this Wednesday with
ambulance response times currently the
worst on record Sky News has seen
firsthand the reality of working on the
front line of emergency care
there are multiple reports in German
media that Berlin has decided it will
send tanks to Ukraine to boost its
Firepower in the war against Russia
and a report has found a severe
disparity between the North and South as
political leaders prepared to gather in
Manchester today to discuss the leveling
opportunity
[Music]
right let's run you through the front
pages then the Ft reports on Germany's
anticipated announcement that it will
send tanks to Ukraine
the guardian leads with that story
calling it a historic move
the telegraph says it would represent a
hammer blow for Russia
the Metro focuses on that ippr report
it's headline simply it's Grim up north
the times looks at a warning that the
UK's economic prospects have declined
leaving a multi-billion pound hole ahead
of the spring budget in March
the eyes says the treasury is rooting
out any tax cuts after being surprised
by recent government borrowing
mail points to those record borrowing
levels saying it shows the need for
growth
they expressed me my warns the
chancellor against any move to increase
the pension age
the mirror leads with mistakes made by
the probation service after a review
Into the murder of Zara Alina calling
them deadly failings
the star reports on an alert about
Chinese spies supposedly using everyday
gadgets against us
and the sun says a UK filmed game show
based on the Netflix hit squid game
turned to real life horror for
contestants
Chicago flavor of what's on the front
page is Mari is back with us now um
delving further inside and a lot to do
with the economy that many of these
headlines have seen on the front pages
following the uh borrowing figures out
yesterday what have you found yeah so
not good news unfortunately after warn
you Nick but um I wanted to start with
this story it seems to be good news when
we sit together I know I'm so sorry I
promise it's not me but there's a story
in the eye and this is all about how
we've had that like you say that data
about public sector debt and this is all
about how essentially those new figures
that we're not expecting to that extent
mean that tax cuts are completely off
the table for Jeremy Hunt in the spring
statement in March so obviously we know
there are still lots of Tory MPS who are
really hoping to have more of a kind of
pro-growth agenda and this is obviously
going to come as a big a disappointment
to them especially on the um kind of Liz
trust backer side so there's some detail
here about how the conservative growth
Group which is made up of kind of Liz
trust backers a bunch of Tory MPS who
essentially want to see growth pushed
and tax cuts as soon as possible the
real question is are they going to
potentially cause problems cause
difficulties for the Prime Minister and
the chancellor if they don't get what
they want in the spring statement it
really depends on kind of how powerful
they end up actually being we don't know
yet it was only formed last week but it
talks about how we know in December at
the government borrowed 27.4 billion
pounds which was more than twice as much
as a year earlier and 10 billion pound
more than the forecast and basically
that was due to the big energy package
to try and help people with their energy
bills and then also combine that with
Rising interest rates and therefore it's
just more expensive to service the debt
in the first place so sorry not the best
news
any glimmer of hope anywhere more bad
news in the times unfortunately Nick so
on the front page of the times similar
story but they've got some interesting
detail from the APR so this is all about
here we go this is all about that how
there's been private submissions to the
treasury from the ABR where they've said
they've overestimated the prospects of
medium-term growth in the UK and
therefore they're having to downgrade
those prospects so they're now saying
that they're actually reducing the
forecasts by between 0.2 and 0.5 due to
witnessing the economy and shortages in
the labor market and it says here
recession this year will be shorter and
shallower than expected but the
long-term economic prospects are
actually Bleaker so more bad news but
we'll just have to see obviously you
never know better things could always
look up but so far it's not looking
great for the Future No but the obr
involved now we remember what happened
with the uh budget the mini budget
didn't we and the quasi-quarting you
know they put that off but Jeremy Hunt
will be Keen to kind of maintain
stability and try and kind of get rid of
the legacy of the mini budget under Liz
truss and cause all right thank you
uh you're watching the early rundown
it's Wednesday and still to come we'll
have the sport and just what sport is
Gareth Bale turning to now he's retired
from football
[Music]